la luz tiene nueve muñecas en su casa de
muñecas ella tiene una más que diana
cuántas muñecas tiene diana escribamos
los datos
lulú tiene nueve muñecas y ella tiene
una más que bien a cuantas muñecas tiene
diana
esto es lo que queremos encontrar
cuando tenemos este tipo de problemas lo
importante es identificar si se tienen
más o menos aquí queremos saber si diana
tiene más o menos muñecas que eeuu lo
aquí dice que ella lulú tiene una más
que bien por lo que lulu tiene más
muñecas que tienes cuantas más una más
viene tendrá una menos que el 1 como
escribimos 1 - qué
- 1 restamos 1
esto es uno menos
aquí decimos que diana tiene una menos
que lula cuántas muñecas tiene diana 8
muñecas
otra forma de hacerlo es dibujar las
muñecas que tiene el uno tiene una dos
tres cuatro
nueve muñecas
y ya tiene una más que diana así que
diana tiene una menos tachamos una de
estas y nos quedan ocho muñecas
hagamos otro problema
la masa de una caja pequeña tiene 7
gramos menos que la masa de la caja
grande la masa de la caja pequeña es de
6 gramos cual es la masa de la caja
grande anotemos los datos la caja
pequeña
la caja pequeña tiene una masa de 6
gramos nos piden encontrar la masa de la
caja grande así que esta es la caja
grande y no sabemos cuál es su masa
el problema nos dice que la caja grande
tiene una masa más grande o una masa
menos grande que es lo que nos dice el
problema nos dicen que la caja pequeña
tiene 7 gramos menos que la caja más
grande así que esta masa es 7 gramos
menor que la de la caja grande esta es
otra forma de decir que la caja grande
tiene 7 gramos más que la caja pequeña +
7 y esto será igual a la masa de la caja
más grande 6 + 7 es igual a 13 y con
esto terminamos